let's hope our Intel was good
like this is the place are you sure
hey everyone this is reviews editor
Peter Brown reading Daniel Starkey's
review of XCOM - War of the Chosin in
the new XCOM 2 expansion war of the
chosen enemies are tougher and your own
troops have more strategic and tactical
counters than ever but they're also more
human and in some ways more fragile
together these feed into not just the
complexity of X comes already robust
chess like play but the human edge as
well
XCOM has always found its grounding in
its characters you as a player are
encouraged to name the members of your
resistance after your friends and family
after some time on the battlefield they
grow more experienced and versatile
developing new skills and finding their
own ad-hoc narrative slices or of the
chosen explores these narratives more
fully first soldiers that spend lots of
time together form close relationships
conferring battlefield stat bonuses as
well as fodder for whatever backstory
you choose to conjure or of the chosen
wants you to use these features kindling
relationships with characters and
leaning on them for your own sort of
moral support so that it can bludgeon
you with hopelessness down the line
target neutralized for every fun little
addition war of the chosen slots and
ex-con - it also adds something more
sinister the eponymous chosen for
example are an elite trio of champions
that are hell-bent on capturing and
torturing your soldiers picking their
minds clean so they can take aim at you
to balance the scales a little you'll
also be able to tap three new factions
for your burgeoning squad the Templars
for example are powerful mind wizards
who loosely counter the Warlock one of
the chosen and a psychic warrior whose
mind has been twisted by obscene power
the Reapers and skirmishers round out
your ranks with stealthy snipers and
gruff short-range assault troops
respectively each of them comes with
special skills so as to not overlap with
your more basic rank-and-file soldiers
[Music]
each of these add-ons might be a solid
inclusion on their own who wouldn't want
cadre of super soldiers to shore up in
the ranks but war of the chosen wouldn't
work without all of them the new
factions are introduced early so players
who finished the base game have some new
me to sink their teeth into everyone
else they get a straightforward
introduction and continue on as normal
the key though is that a Reaper can help
you expand your tactical options early
on where stages bereft of the
reverse-engineered laser cannons that
show up dozens of hours later could use
a little bit more excitement this makes
their first few hours a bit easier than
the rest of the game but this affords
you room to experiment before the truly
punishing moments appear after all
characters who aren't watched have a
tendency to be ripped apart or shot to
bits having a souped-up fighter in the
field affords you some flexibility as
with a queen in chess you can adjust
your plans on the fly leveraging
additional power at key moments either
for offense or defense but as with the
Queen losing such a valuable soldier can
hurt doubly so
the chosen play a similar role dropping
into missions and harassing your team's
whenever possible they learn and grow
from battle to battle - it's not quite
as robust as the Nemesis system from
shadow of Mordor but the chosen will
adapt your tactics covering their
weaknesses over time that makes them
exceptional foes down the line and in
essence they become bosses that dog you
and wear you down an omnipresent threat
that could hit at any time as the game
marches on you are beset on all sides by
powerful foes that force you to adapt as
well your own soldiers might grow but
when your elite squads are picked off or
they've grown weary and fatigued or when
they lose their best friend or lover
that loss is palpable or of the chosen
packs in appreciable new layers of
tactical and strategic depth that
breathe new life into what was already
one of the genres best games but it is
once again the humanity of the fight
that binds it all together new factions
wouldn't work without the new challenges
and new bonds are strained by foes that
seek to quash opposition not with
overwhelming force but by cracking your
will you share not only in new powers
but in the pervasive defeat when they
are taken from you everything that war
of the chosen brings from elite soldiers
to the deeper connections between your
squads feels like a living part of the
XCOM universe if you like your deep
strategy and brutal turn-based tactics
alongside brilliant interplay between
camp and emergent drama there is none
better than war of the chosen
[Music]
you